and if you read it it's it's it's
informative do you know women are more
likely to be violent towards their
children than men
I can't believe that
yeah because flashbacks my mom straight
away
but you know what because because I I
think that's because men
were your father they had the threat of
violence and you really have to do it
yeah yeah I remember my dad just looking
at me yeah there is a big difference
between my mom and dad looking at me oh
I had a
flashbacks yeah there is there is such
an aura of a man yeah
that
they don't even need to speak to command
respect from children
when my dad when I did something wrong
my mom didn't even need to say she just
said I'm get I'm gonna I'm gonna tell
your dad and me and my brothers fixed up
I remember the first time I ever got
arrested the beat and I received made
sure I never did that again so
there is an authority figure in a mill
that cannot be exchanged for a woman
there is a way a man raises children
with authority and in love
that cannot be exchanged so I see why
we're like this I see why Society is
being like this I see why women are like
this even on the point of I know I touch
a lot on the boys but I can speak for uh
from a male a female perspective the
first woman
uh the first man or woman learns to love
and submit to is her father so far
because he's the only man who can look
at your daughter's eyes give you
everything you want and or anything in
return he's the only man who should be
who will not take anything back in
return in pure love so unless you have a
good understanding of
how to love a man and how a man should
love you you have no blueprint for love
so what do you think monogamy's the way
forward
I'm a Christian so I have a traditional
mindset but I also know the type of men
the type of men men want to be
they might it may not be consistent with
their worldview but for my personal
worldview yeah in terms of the fabric of
society it starts at home so I'm
interested because obviously you
practice polygamy right
um I'm in a monogamous relationship now
but by Nature I am polygamous yeah
could you how would you be how would it
be raising a child in that type of
environment
um what do you say the only reason I can
afford to be polygamous is because I
don't believe in marriage
um left and right I've seen marriages
fall apart and I don't want to be a part
of it I'm scared of it I'm scared of
what I could lose
um and because of that and I'm also like
the type of guy that needs a lot of
attention needs a lot of affection one
person it's very hard for one person to
give me all that because they get
suffocated
um so I don't think I'm the best example
to
to throw in there but uh I do believe
that
a proper family where kids are being
raised should be monogamous
so what about you
huh your point of view or on what my
numbers
The Way Forward yeah I grew up in a
homework I
I've seen Society Society deteriorate
as marriage breaks down so the less the
more single parent homes there are the
more problems you start to see in
society by another time I've seen it I
grew up in the state yeah where we grew
up in the same environment but the only
difference for me in regards to them was
the fact that I had two people then I
didn't because I always had that
deterrent there was always
if this goes a step too far I don't have
to deal with what I've got at home
literally I I got a neighbor I grew up
with won't mention his name but
people who know me will know exactly who
he is he went down for for murder
uh 25.
and my mom always used to say to me
growing up
not to be so close to him because she
mama was older in hindsight I see
exactly what she she was talking about
her mom used to have different men come
around
her dad his dad was never around and
there is and he was always the sort of
guy that I in some some way used to
follow until my dad stepped in and
removed me because
he the way he used to run life was was
purely based on on society's influence
that answers you know being coming from
well she's a single mother she was a
single mother
he kind of ran his own rule around his
own mother and this was what I'm talking
about 10 when I was out in frimsby park
so and fast forward later I think about
must have been about six years ago and
now six seven years ago I'm 31 so he's
mid-20s he went down for murder but my
when I told my mum this she said I I saw
this coming it happens a lot I saw this
coming which like I'll read the stats
because you know I've read them before
about 63 of suicides are from children
from single mother homes 90 of
homelessness and runaway children are
from single mother homes 85 of children
with behavioral disorders are from
single mother homes eighty percent of
convicted rapists are from single mother
homes 71 of high school dropouts are
from single mother homes 80 of youths in
prison are from single mother homes that
checks out can I just say something um
I'm very blessed man in a lot of ways in
terms of my family like I'm not minted
but I can pay my own rent so my mom and
my my dad never beat my mom or me or my
sister there was no violence at all
and in school I had a very bad time in
school in England I came to England I
was 14 so from 14 to 16 my schooling
consisted of physical verbal and racial
abuse from all people when I was 20
somebody sliced my throat and tried to
kill me I would sell cracking Harry in
this country I have Mom and Dad who
didn't beat me and I still so what I'm
trying to point out so there's
differences between what I read in this
book that you can expose to Violent
environment and still not be violent or
you be exposed to violence and that's
when you become violent when your
parents expose you to violence or you
don't have no parents or want to yeah
and you live in environment violent
environment are you going to be part of
that violence and you're going to
contribute towards it and then you're
going to get 25 to level 25. like I got
very lucky I'm alive that's 16 years ago
somebody sliced my throat and tried to
murder me and I have mum and dad who
didn't even beat me they got
universities degrees I don't even got
that but that's that's a very unique
situation that I'm from how I I came
through the challenges that were
presented to me but if I didn't have a
dad or a mom or both that like listen
are scared of my mom she I'm scared
still now so I got fortunate and blessed
in a lot of ways and yet my life still
had a lot of violent outcomes do you
guys think that women that get IVF are
selfish
without a husband where they just get in
vitro fertilization and just have a kid
on their own and choose to be a single
mother
no but that is does affect the child
you don't think they're selfish why
because I mean
let's say let's say like you're a
lesbian couple
okay okay
I'm not talking about lesbian couples
I'm talking about single mothers oh
I think even single mothers can have
people in their lives who's an effective
role model for the child so I don't
think it necessarily means oh they're
selfish and I feel like you don't think
it's selfish to put your kid at every
statistical disadvantage you possibly
could a statistic is a statistic it
doesn't mean it's gonna happen if they
as many of you know know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible